you've probably heard about the latest
Disney flop over a Thanksgiving weekend
but um I haven't personally had a chance
to gloat over it so let's talk about
that uh this is the daily wires report
on it Disney's new animated film wish
failed to perform well at the box office
over Thanksgiving holiday weekend this
especially tough for the studio
following the massive flop of the
Marvels earlier this month wish debuted
in third place at the box office
grossing just 19.5 million in its
three-day opening
weekend um which is
for a for an original Disney film on
Thanksgiving weekend $20 million is uh
abysmal and it got 31 million over the
5-day Thanksgiving weekend which is also
abysmal this was significantly less than
forecasted and doesn't come close to
recouping the $200 million production
budget and I always have to remind
everyone that when you hear about the
production budgets that's that's only uh
the tip of the iceberg because that
doesn't count the marketing
budget um which could be even more than
than the production
budget so the fantasy musical Stars
Ariana debose as the main character Asha
and Chris Pine as the villain King
magnifico the synopsis says young Asha
makes a wish so powerful that it's
answered by a cosmic force a little ball
of Boundless Energy called star with
star's help Asha must save her kingdom
from King magnifico and prove that when
the will of one courageous human
connects with the magic of the Stars
wondrous things can
happen and wish has a 49% uh rating on
Rotten Tomato so critics don't like it
either audiences don't care critics
don't like it's just a it's a flop all
around and this is you know there was a
a run there there was a stretch and
we'll talk about this in a second
where like every Disney film was not
only a smash success commercially but
was also critically acclaimed if you go
to Rotten Tomatoes however much stock
you put in Rotten Tomatoes which I think
that Rotten Tomatoes is is you know it's
actually it gets a bad repap but it's
there are exceptions but it generally
gives you a pretty good idea of whether
a movies is good or not um so it used to
be that every film is a is a commercial
smash success and every film has like
95% of rten tomatoes and uh now the
exact opposite is the case nearly every
film they're putting out is a flop and
uh everybody hates it and even the
critics can't find a reason to like
it now um this this is just Thanksgiving
weekend but really uh this whole year
has been Bleak here's IGN on that um
after wish's underwhelming opening this
past weekend the spotlight is on Disney
once again and the rough year this once
incredibly reliable brand has had to
specify as variety pointed out in a
recent analysis of this troubling box
office streak Disney looks primed to end
2023 with a single with without without
a single movie Crossing the1 billion
doll Mark to be clear the billion dollar
Mark is not an easy one to cross only
two movies Barbie and the Super Mario
Brothers movie have done it this year
but that used to be nearly a given for
Disney um we're not going to count 2020
2021 which were abnormal years because
of the covid-19
lockdowns
um but going back to prepandemic times
Disney had a whopping seven billion doll
hits in 2019 alone they had seven films
in 2019 that went over a billion
dollars uh last year they had one which
was
Avatar and this year they have none so
it is trending in exactly the uh wrong
direction if you're Disney you know the
holidays are here and while you're out
shopping for your kids family and
friends don't forget to shop for your
pets too I know I never do give your dog
the gift of a healthier and happier life
with Ruff greens naturopathic Dr Dennis
black the founder of Ruff greens is uh
focused on improving the health of every
dog in America before I started feeding
my dog rough greens I had no idea that
dog food is dead food it contains very
little nutritional value think about it
nutrition isn't Brown it's green let
rough greens bring your dogs food back
to life rough grain is a supplement that
contains all the necessary vitamins
mineral minerals probiotics Omega oils
digestive enzymes and antioxidants that
your dog needs you don't have to go out
and buy new dog food just sprinkle rough
Greens on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving about rough
greens it supports healthy joints
improves bad breath boosts energy levels
and so much more we are what we eat and
that goes for our dogs too naturopathic
Dr Dennis black is so confident Ruff
greens will improve your dog's health
he's offering my listeners a free
jumpstart trial bag so your dog can try
get a free jump start trial bag
delivered straight to your door just a
few business days go to Ru greens.com
mat or call 844 ru700 that's rfffg
greens.com or call 844 ru700 today we've
talked about why Disney is falling apart
um partly it's a it's a total lack of
originality
you know that that's some of this like
these movies just aren't very good
they're not original they're not
Innovative they're they're not
interesting it's the same thing over and
over again uh you know it turns out that
these franchises you can only go back to
the well like eventually the well does
dry up now this wish film is not a
franchise film this is actually their
attempt at something like a you know an
original film but it's bad and um nobody
cares nobody wants to see it but then
the second thing is also um
and Disney has recently acknowledged
this in fact that their foray into the
culture War has been a total disaster
for
them
so that's the other thing that we should
acknowledge here and that you're not
going to see this certainly you're not
going to see any mainstream media report
that acknowledges this but it's
true that uh Disney you know we can put
them in the Bud Light
category that that's it's a big part of
the story
here that their
failure is at least partially a big in
in in large part I think um a success of
conservatives in the culture
War you know Disney decided to go to war
against conservatives in a very direct
and kind of deliberate and explicit way
and they lost they lost the
war and now they have a a year at least
a year of flops to show for
it so again you're not going to find any
media report that acknowledges that
you're not going to say that that will
not happen but it's the
truth the truth is that we pulled a we
pulled a Bud Light on Disney
so when you look at the success of
conservative boycott
efforts um and even boycott isn't I
don't I don't think that's quite the
right term exactly it's not EX exactly a
boycott it's kind of a branding
effort okay you have these companies
that are trying to Brand us a certain
way as conservatives certainly that's
what Disney's doing and we have turned
around and branded
them so it's not so much boycott as
branding we successfully branded
budlight you know a far-left crazy comp
woke company and it destroyed
them and we have branded Disney the same
and it's killing them
too so this is these are these are major
successes for conservatives in the
culture War these are the kinds of
successes that uh that seemed impossible
for years and that and that that even
now you have conservatives this is not
possible you can't you can't take you
you know you can't make a dent in a
company like Disney oh yes you can
because we
did this is not all happen stance this
is this is
deliberate um and even in in spite of
that you know this is what makes it so
remarkable is
that there's probably nothing budlight
can do budlight is screwed forever
there's just nothing they can
do uh Disney I mean they could come back
from this like all they have to do is
say look we okay we we're bound out of
the culture where we want we want
nothing to do with it
anymore and and uh and then but then
also start making films that people want
to see just take the wokeness and the
political correctness out of the films
entirely this wish film from what I
understand it's it's uh at least by
recent Disney standards it's not like
overly
woke but it still is because of course
you got the white male who's the villain
and then you've got the protagonist has
to be this young brown girl and she
wants to Grant everybody's wishes and
the greedy horrible white man does so
it's like
they they can't pull back from that if
they just pulled back from that and
started telling good stories put the
wokeness aside put the political
correctness
aside
um if they just did that then they could
start churning out billion dollar movies
again but they they can't it's like they
can't stop themselves at this point
they're on a they're on a train that
they can't stop and now they're paying
the price for it which I think is
fantastic thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcast